sort of punishment reserved for the
worst criminals or most severely
disturbed mental health patients being
locked up alone 24 hours a day in an
empty sealed room but that's his life
for Bethany a British teenager who has
committed no crime she's autistic and a
victim of problems in the NHS that means
she can't get the treatment nor the care
that she needs she's been locked up for
almost three years and even her family
has only been allowed physical contact
with Bethany through a hatch in the door
the latest figures show that many people
like Bethany have fallen through the
cracks of what campaign is called a
broken system currently 2,250 people
with a learning disability or autism
from England being inappropriately held
in mental health units of those 235
under the age of 18 355 have been in
these institutions for 10 years or more
and that is despite a recent report that
said the system fails people with a
learning disability or autism who are
segregated and called it not fit for
purpose well this is what NHS England
told us Bethany's case continues to be
assessed by expert clinicians and we are
working with her family and also Bethany
herself to agree and manage an ongoing
plan for her case and Andrews health
care and NHS England have put in place
changes to improve the care of people
with autistic spectrum disorder
including new policies and systems for
monitoring compliance with a Mental
Health Action code of practice in
relation to seclusion and long-term
segregation and improved equality
training for staff that's all well and
good but what does it actually mean
Bethany's father Jeremy is with us hi
that was your hand wasn't it that we saw
touching your daughter's that situation
is worse now despite the acknowledgement
by NHS England that they have damaged
Bethany's well-being despite other
parties admitting that her delayed the
community has been delayed they have now
moved my daughter to a unit
that is not even autism specific they
have no ability to care for my child
they have no hatch in the door I can't
hold a hand I talk to my child through
an intercom it's it's humiliating for
both of us for the whole family and this
is because of a broken failed system how
does it make you feel angry sad confused
that we can have this legal action where
so much was admitted and they do this to
my daughter why did they move her they
moved her first to a unit that was
reasonably close to home and that unit
was very small with a very small team of
staff that unit worked it did brilliant
work with Beth within weeks she was out
of the cell she was in the community we
would take the dogs to her we would go
for a walk it was an adolescent unit and
Bethany turned 18 so they placed it in
the first available bed they had why
does she need to be confined like this
Bethany is autistic her part of the
spectrum means she has a massive level
of anxiety all the time imagine being
shutting a car full of bees your basic
instincts would be to either remove
yourself from that situation and to run
away from it or to start swatting those
bees that is how Beth presents if you
remove the bees remove the anxiety you
have an ordinary 18 year old who loves
life who loves dancing you put her
somewhere that doesn't have that support
and you have somebody that swats bees
and wants to run away you lock her away
she can't run away she's left without
one option how else could she be treated
what do you want to happen what she
needs in her care plan is for people who
understand her presentation who
understand the triggers for the behavior
who can keep Bethany occupied in the
activities that she enjoys
remove the anxiety's you don't have the
displays of challenging behavior that
Beth can resort to I would love to have
Bethany home more than anything that
would require a team of people to
facilitate that that's not impossible
Beth should be in a home the authorities
are saying that they are there to
basically protect Beth from herself and
they are working to move her to a
bespoke community placement that work
has only just begun
Beth has been in this system for three
years why has it taken so long why has
it taken court legal action to force
them to start doing that piece of work
now what impact it had on the family a
massive a massive impact childhood
should be full of memories of parties
and Christmases and birthdays and exam
results Beth's life is measured in
hospital units and locked doors of being
held down restrained injected because
she's autistic because she's failed and
Beth is not alone as your leading said
2,200 people in the same situation
and these people are hidden away from
society this isn't something that
anybody talks about society fails these
people as much as the system what is her
day consistent Beth lives in a room that
is 10 foot wide 14 foot long with a
toilet and shower at one end there is a
mattress but the other end she is
allowed crayons
she has a perspex window that she can
interact with the care staff on the
phone the other day Bethany asked me for
some dolls that smelt like real babies
because she's lonely Beth was ready to
do her GCSEs before they put her into
first unit Beth is not some animal that
needs restraining she leads spawn the
support is there what's it like when you
go to see her and then you have to leave
I I draw on Beth in this strength to
survive that I don't know how she does
it it's it's horrific it's like the
scene in Hannibal Lecter where Clarice
Starling goes to meet dr. Lecter for the
first time you walk down a corridor and
then you see your your child behind the
screen it's it's heartbreaking is
destroying when you come home I'm lucky
I have a wonderful family I have friends
I have hobbies that I can engage in and
take my mind off it I I have that Beth
doesn't Beth is in that room 24/7 how'd
you see her future given the right
support there is no reason why Bethany
can't go on to live a proper and full
life it's why I won't mention her
surname that Beth has a future the
professionals involved in Bethany's care
state she has a wonderful future ahead
of her but at the moment the system
isn't in the way of that are you hopeful
Bethany says the answer to that there
are two things in Bethany's life
professionals and unicorns she believes
in unicorns some believe in
professionals they need to prove to us
that they can support my daughter you
know you're gonna have to keep fighting
for Jane I won't stop and I won't stop
fighting for a live patient in the her
situation as well
never you should appreciate you taking
the time to come in and do um may be
mentioned that would you've been on the
program today and tell her what you've
been shown on her because she really
loves the fact that so many people are
listening so hard
to her story did she like the dolls she
loves the dolls she absolutely loves
those dolls fantastic and well I'm glad
we can leave you with a smile thank you
keep in touch then I just know what we
can do to help absolutely sure you tell
my time thanks thanks very much yes yes
do do seriously I'd love to have you any
time thank you